nahún todo ha pasado los dos últimos
días al teléfono los testimonios de sus
familiares son espantosos su hermano el
jefe de la aldea de dallas ago fue
asesinado y varios miembros de su
familia los terroristas llegaron por
docenas en motocicletas
además los terroristas vinieron y le
dijeron a la gente ustedes no son
musulmanes se llevaron a los hombres y
los fusilaron sistemáticamente
incendiaron el mercado quemaron las
tiendas saquearon tomaron lo que querían
y se fueron
y sobre el helvético es donde sacas de
ese nivel aporte es don't play y son
parte de la saga se encuentra a 700
kilómetros al noreste de bamako cerca de
la frontera con burkina faso el ataque
que también tuvo como objetivo otras
aldeas fue al parecer una represalia por
una operación del ejército a principios
de junio
de wii hubo enfrentamientos con los
terroristas hubo muertos en el bando
terrorista unas 12 personas y hay de
amor don usted tories el gobernador de
la región de bonn ya garra acudió el
lunes al lugar de los hechos y las
autoridades de transición tras un largo
silencio confirmaron finalmente el
elevado número de víctimas en un
comunicado acusaron a los combatientes
del grupo yihadista de la katiba máxima
afiliado al caída y del cual varios
miembros han sido formalmente
identificados las fuerzas de la onu en
mali la misma condenó estos y otros
ataques en la región de gao un poco más
al norte y anunció que está llevando a
cabo una investigación sobre los hechos